>> ANDREW CUOMO TAKING A VICTORY
LAP AS HE PROMOTES THE LAUNCH OF
HIS NEW BOOK LEADERSHIP LESSONS
FROM THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
>> IN THE HALFTIME OF THIS,
WRITING A BOOK, A RETROSPECTIVE
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT CELEBRATING
THE THINGS YOU DID RIGHT FEELS
STRANGE.
>> IT IS NOT A CELEBRATION AT
ALL.
THE GAME ISN’T OVER.
TODD: PART OF NEW YORK CITY
REENTERED LOCKDOWN AND YESTERDAY
THE GOVERNOR SAID A SECOND
STATEWIDE LOCKDOWN IS POSSIBLE.
ARE THERE LOSSES PREMATURE?
JOINING US A CITY COUNCILMAN JOE
BORELLI.
>> SORRY ABOUT THE PATHETIC
CIRCUMSTANCES.
TODD: LET’S LOOK AT THESE
NUMBERS, NEW YORK STATE
CORONAVIRUS DEPTH 33,301 TOTAL
STATE DEATH AND YOU CAN SEE 6600
NURSING HOME DEATHS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE TAKE ISSUE WITH
A BOOK LIKE THIS.
DO YOU?
>> THEY CERTAINLY SHOULD.
GIVEN THOSE NUMBERS WE SAW MORE
DEATHS THAN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
OF FRANCE, AN ENTIRE LARGE
POPULATED EUROPEAN COUNTRY, NEW
YORK STATE STILL HAS MORE
DEATHS, WHAT IS SO INSULTING IS
AS PEOPLE ARE STILL DYING, STILL
GETTING SICK, AS THE UNCERTAINTY
CONTINUES AND BUSINESSES WERE
CLOSING THIS WAS A GUY WHO USE
THE GOVERNMENT NOT ONLY FOR
CONTEMPORARY IS NOTES FOR A
FUTURE BOOK BUT WAS GLAD HANDING
PUBLISHERS, SHOPPING FOR AGENTS,
WRITING THIS BOOK, THIS IS IN
THE THICK OF THIS PANDEMIC WHEN
WE LOST PEOPLE MORE THAN ANY
OTHER STATE EASILY BUT MORE THAN
PLACES LIKE FRANCE AND SPAIN.
IT IS UPSETTING, IT IS
TROUBLING.
I DON’T THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
A BOYCOTT, GIVEN THE LAST BOOK
SALES, 3000 COPIES IT DOESN’T
SEEM PEOPLE ARE INTERESTED IN
HIM AS AN AUTHOR TO BEGIN WITH
BUT PEOPLE SHOULD UNDERSTAND HOW
INSULTING IT IS FOR FAMILIES TO
SEE THIS MAN PROFITING OFF OF
THIS BOOK.
>> ONE OF THOSE FAMILIES IS
METEOROLOGIST JANICE DEAN, SHE’S
BEEN FIGHTING THIS BATTLE DAY IN
AND DAY OUT, BOTH OF HER IN-LAWS
DIED IN ASSISTED LIVING CARE
FACILITIES, SHE’S ONE OF MANY
PEOPLE WHO STILL WANT QUESTIONS
ON THIS AND HE WAS ON YESTERDAY
WITH WILLIE GIESE AND ASKED THE
QUESTION AND LISTEN TO HOW THIS
EXCHANGE WENT DOWN.
>> WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED ABOUT
THE EARLY STAGES YOU CAN APPLY,
WAS IT A MISTAKE TO SEND THOSE
COVID-19 PATIENTS BACK INTO
NURSING HOMES?
>> THE FIRST LESSON FOR THE
NATION, HOW DID YOU NOT KNOW THE
VIRUS WAS COMING TO THE UNITED
STATES?
SHANNON: THAT’S NOT AN ANSWER TO
THAT QUESTION?
>> THIS IS WHY HE IS DODGING FOR
SO LONG THAT HE HAS PEOPLE LIKE
JANICE DEAN WHO IS UP IN ALBANY
EVERY WEEKEND ON HER TIME OFF
MEETING WITH LEGISLATORS,
HOSTING RALLIES AND RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT GOVERNOR CUOMO.
TALKING ABOUT WHATEVER HE
GOVERNOR COULD HAVE DONE BETTER
TO PREVENT LOSS OF LIFE,
GOVERNOR CUOMO IS ONE OF THE
ONLY STATE GOVERNORS, WE ARE
ABLE TO POINT TO SOMETHING HE
DID THAT ACTUALLY CAUSED LOSS OF
LIFE IN THIS PANDEMIC, ALMOST
UNPRECEDENTED AROUND THE WORLD.
THE MARCH 20 FIFTH ORDER THAT
PLACED PEOPLE WITH COVID-19 IN
NURSING HOMES PUTTING PEOPLE IN
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
ONE COULD IMAGINE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HE DID.
THIS BOOK IS AS RELEVANT AS
NAPOLEON WRITING HOW TO INVADE
RUSSIA.
IT IS SO UPSETTING, SO MANY
PEOPLE, TO SEE THIS MAN HAVING
THIS VICTORY TOUR WHERE HE GETS
THE SOFTBALL QUESTIONS ON THE
MORNING NEWS SHOWS.
JILLIAN: A LOT OF PEOPLE SAY HE
WOULD BE BETTER SERVED TO SAY
HERE IS WHAT WE LEARNED AND WHAT